welcome back to a20 in this short video
you want to discuss length contraction
we want to actually derive length
contraction
and we do this with an experiment the
question is how long is bob spacecraft
the experiment is conducted by taking
two pictures so illustrated here the
first picture is when
alice's and bob spacecrafts just start
to meet
um bob's relative to analysis is moving
with the velocity v and we take the
second picture when the back of bob's
spacecraft is meeting the front of
alice's just like it's shown here
and the pictures
take pictures of clocks
so in the first picture we we see
alice's clock show a ta1
and bob's
tb1 and for the second equivalently we
see ta2 and tb2
so your task is now to express the
length of bob's spacecraft
for as alice sees this from these
pictures and as bob does see it from his
own pictures
by comparing the time and the velocity
pause the video and try to work this out
so i did this here for you
you calculate um
the length we can do this with the
velocity and simply the product of the
velocity and the time difference in the
pictures as shown
of those two clocks we see this for
alice
and we see this for bob
and now we can start to compare
for bob ls now is moving
um so
the time difference
in alice's
clock will be smaller by one over gamma
compared to what bob sees in his own
clocks so for bob says or bob says
your clock is slow
um so we can use this we can then
calculate um the length of the
spacecraft
as alice sees it
equal to v times delta ta
and we just use the time relation here
in this equation and we find that the
lengths are actually not the same the
length as ls is one over gamma times the
length as prophecies of the very same
spacecraft
so the lengths
of the spacecraft are not the same as
seen by alice
and seen by bob
now here you have to see that in this
example what i just did
is i changed around who's moving and was
resting so here the observation of alice
of bob spacecraft is that of the moving
spacecraft so ls sees a moving
spacecraft which is shorter than the
spacecraft itself at length at rest
so how can we resolve this um alice will
argue that the two clocks bob used are
actually not synchronized
and
if you paid a lot of attention you see
that
i'm actually not looking at the same
clock i'm having i had a look at the
clock at the beginning of the spacecraft
at the end of the spacecraft
and while they are synchronized for bob
they're not synchronized for alice
who's right
both are right they're just observing
events or sequences events with two
different reference frames